so five weeks ago you haven't ever
created a piece of content ever on the
internet and for people who know me know
that i've created a lot of content on
the internet
i was like an email at work type guy
and uh basically my brothers all give me
a hard time they all give me [ __ ] all
the time about the content
to the point where literally i got one
brother whoever whenever he gets mad at
me
dude go back on youtube he's the youtube
star that's literally the extent of my
brother and i's uh relationship
but joseph out of nowhere one day sends
me a camera text message
email whatever it was probably email
because the email guy and
hit me with uh what do you think about
this and he had basically created a sub
stack
and he'd written a first article but
hadn't published it yet and we just went
back and looked and how many subscribers
did you have
uh two two you me and my girlfriend lexi
so i was subscriber number three yeah i
think polina was subscriber number four
four there was a mystery subscriber
number five and then he went back to
that went back to four
so it was a slow start
but we figured out that it was actually
the fifth subscriber was joseph on his
work email and he unsubscribed from
himself
so that that tells you how great the
content was on day one
but uh what's the point or like why uh
why this content the the point is
the business and money behind sports
right so i think i think it's always
interesting obviously
you i we've always been interested in
the sports side of it for sure right
growing up playing different sports
everything like that i think that's an
easy one
and then maybe as i got older as we got
older right like the business side
becomes much more interesting right the
deals you start hearing about different
contracts
partnerships uh marketing brand stuff
things like that right so
i think there's a huge audience for that
type of stuff and
when you look around there's not really
i mean there's definitely people doing
it but i think most people are probably
either like
really good at the sports side or really
good at the business side and they don't
do a good job like
maybe partnering the two together right
so that's kind of where the niche i saw
was and and i started writing about it
and pretty much the person who like made
this niche famous with darren rovell
20 years ago but darren rovell shout out
robel yeah
has gotten a little bit older and kind
of the demographic that he served on the
platforms he served
have kind of aged with him and so
there's an opportunity for somebody to
come in
and basically be the next ravel right
yeah young gun that's young
what up robo let's go um so before we
get into any of the stories
uh like i said earlier joseph has gone
viral on the internet viral and like
capital v-i-r-a-l uh like viral viral
like so viral that he's looking at me
like hey man how come you don't go viral
like me
yeah so when we say he's gone viral
let's see what you had one tweet thread
that uh got 11 000 likes on twitter
you had one that got 40 000 likes on
twitter today you got a tweet that's got
six thousand
and and today wasn't a thread today so
joe has gone from non-existent on
twitter five weeks ago to how many 20
000 followers now 20k yeah 20k followers
most of you listen to been trying your
whole life to get 20k followers you
don't have 20k followers
joe did it in five weeks they all came
from you
no we'll get to that in a second too uh
so
uh not only that you got the email
newsletter he's got thousands of people
already signed up on there
and the whole idea is basically what
you're just going to keep creating
content telling these stories
daily daily yeah is daily like
is that a flex well you got to say it
twice
otherwise people don't get it you know i
mean yours is daily right so you create
the content
i don't tell people daily daily i just
say it once yes i'm gonna go with twice
twice daily daily uh yeah creating
content every day send it out in the
morning
could be anything right you've seen i
mean you've seen them obviously for
those that have subscribed it's
so you break down the revenue behind
leagues player contracts
uh great investment deals you speculate
on what certain teams or companies
should do
like pretty much anything business and
sports anything business and sports
could be
you know stories of great investments uh
where i think the space is going in the
future uh how the nba makes money
concussion issues in the nfl all right
stop breaking it could be anything
listen the reason why i want you to come
on here so we're five weeks in so
this sunday is we're recording on sunday
we're going to release in a day or two
is the end of five weeks it's like a
little check-in we're gonna do these
periodic
but i also just want to kind of give you
a hard time and bust your balls so
how have you gone viral on the internet
you created a thread before we get into
any of the sports stores
you created a thread that said
i got 12 000 followers in four weeks on
twitter
to talk about a flex
using these six principles and what were
the six principles
uh let's let's go through them right so
one was just to be
be clear about what your your your
audience should expect right so
you tell them the business of money
behind sports it's right in the bio very
clear about it that's what you're gonna
get when you come to my profile those
those are the tweets you can expect
right um all right that's a good one
that's one all right
two was what uh engineer
virality virality fiberality if you're
gonna go viral viral you gotta be able
to say you gotta be able to pronounce it
yeah yeah orality virality virality yeah
say it five times that could be
difficult
yeah engineer virality um basically
construct tweets that have the
opportunity to go viral um try to
increase your chances obviously part of
it is luck right as
all you guys know but you know don't be
scared to ask people for retweets
all right let's just address the hello
elephant in the room
so i got a lot of followers on twitter
joseph had no followers on twitter
of course he is not an
idiot and he said to me hey i'm gonna
start tweeting now your idea was this
was not my idea this was his idea
was to every night do a thread based on
what he wrote in the morning in the
email so he wrote a story
in the email and then that night he
would basically break it into the summit
on twitter yes summary sorry
well one of the first one gta was in the
first or second week
uh went viral i got twenty thousand yeah
second week it exploded
and the way that it exploded not because
it was
uh complete luck there was luck involved
was i retweeted it i think polina
retweeted it darren rovell who's got two
million followers retweeted it
a number of uh people in the media and
then professional sports retweeted it
like it went viral
right when you wrote this thread about
hey i got 12 000 followers in four weeks
pretty much 20 of the comments were it's
only because you know
me and plana yeah there's but the point
is
the content's good yeah and some people
realize that obviously right
um my favorite is who was the guy who
was taking the threats and kept driving
kevin g
we're not we're not gonna we're not
gonna give kevin g's twitter account now
because i don't know if he wants that i
don't know if he listens to this but
shout out kevin g
yeah you're all over it man he's a homie
yeah
he he literally people were talking
junkies he's like the bouncer of twitter
for us
and he was just dropping the threads and
being like yeah i'm sure i'm sure
oh yeah pomp's got 11 000 brothers
i'm like dude this guy's legit